IKY SANDORFY: Hi, everybody.
My name is Iky, I look
after Google Play business
development for apps and games.
I'm based in Tel Aviv.
And I look after our business
in Middle East and Africa.
Here today, we have an exciting
panel of really cool panelists
from game companies
that have all
had significant launches
in the last year or so.
And we wanted to pick
their brain a little bit
and learn from your experiences
over the last year on how
you really took risk
off your game launches
and improved its
initial performance
by really developing at
scale, and then launching
once you're ready, and
finding that right balance
between a good launch strategy,
a good production cycle.
We figured that developing
and launching games today
is becoming an increasingly
expensive proposition
and development costs
have been skyrocketing,
you need to launch
with a good story line,
with proven mechanics,
with amazing graphics.
And at the same time, you
need to appeal to an audience
with a shortening attention
span, increased acquisition
cost, and real high expectations
for high quality games.
So, all in all, it's
becoming much more
tricky to launch a hit, and
to launch a success upfront,
yet there is a couple of
other tools and learnings
you can really leverage
to understand early
where your strengths lie
and where to best process
with the game in order
to ensure the best
possible success
once you're actually
ready for a global
production launch.
So I'd love to invite
our four distinguished
panelists from really
cool game companies
making a diverse range of really
awesome and highly addictive
games.
Please, join me onstage,
George Abramovici from King;
Jens Begomann CEO, Wooga;
Saad Choudri, Chief Commercial
Officer at Miniclip;
and Sergei Zaitsev,
Business Development
Director, Playrigs.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
IKY SANDORFFY: Awesome.
Thank you so much guys for
joining really excited to have
you on stage and
just an FYI, I have
a couple of questions prepared
but please don't hesitate.
We have a couple of minutes at
the end if there's any audience
questions, just feel free to
shout out or raise your hand,
we'll try to accommodate
as many as we can.
And we'll have a break later
on, during which you can pick
this gentleman's brain as well.
Sorry guys, if I kind of
scheduled your breaks now
already.
Awesome.
Sergei, let's start with you.
All the way to the end.
How are you doing?
All good?
SERGEI ZAITSEV:
All good, all good.
Thank you for hosting us here,
we've got a lot to tell you.
IKY SANDORFFY: You've had
a massive hit last year
with "Gardenscapes"
and now create
a pretty cool
follow-on hit, which
seems to be breaking
the banks and reaching
quite a lot of audiences
with "Homeescapes".
So I wanted to ask
very specifically,
how and when did you make
that decision to move over
and to fork off some of
your team's resources
to start developing a
new title and how did you
split the resources
between continuing
to develop for "Gardenscapes"
while also developing
"Homescapes"?
SERGEI ZAITSEV: Thank
you for that question.
So Playrix has a long history,
and it was very successful
in PC-downloadable games.
We had "Gardenscapes"
and the spin off,
which was around
renovating the house.
It was called Mansion Makeover.
So the spin off in
PC-downloadable world
was even more successful than
the story about the garden.
So it was pretty logical
for us to continue the story
and build a game around--
when we saw the success
of "Gardenscapes",
it was very logical
for us to build a game
around renovating a house.
So we were pretty sure
that the concept will work,
so that's why we
made the decision.
And talking about resources,
the interesting thing
that we didn't move anyone from
"Gardenscapes" to "Homescapes"
and we collected the team behind
"Homescapes" from scratch.
So we were developing the
game for one and a half years,
and initially it was 10
people just from scratch,
and then the team rapidly
grew to more than 60 people.
Right now, it's
growing even more.
So yeah.
So we didn't move any
resources, and we just
seek for top talent, and
we have the knowledge.
We had a very good experience
with "Gardenscapes".
And when we were
making "Homescapes",
we tried to make a game,
which is not a sequel,
but we wanted to
create a game, which
was interesting to play and
parallel with "Gardenscapes".
So we wanted to
change some mechanics,
but we wanted to stay
in the same universe.
We wanted to expand
the franchise.
IKY SANDORFFY: So essentially,
you haven't really
moved anybody from
one title to the other
in terms of resourcing.
You really have staffed
an entirely new team.
SERGEI ZAITSEV: Yes.
Sure.
Of course, there was a
lot of shared knowledge
from "Gardenscapes" team
to "Homescapes" team,
but in terms of resources,
we didn't move artists, game
designers, and a lot of guys.
IKY SANDORFFY: Really cool.
Are these two teams competing
now internally as well?
SERGEI ZAITSEV: I would
call it like a corporation.
IKY SANDORFFY: It's a fair.
So I just wanted to bring
this up in terms of retention.
We discussed earlier
that retentions
seems to be becoming more and
more important as a true KPI
of business success.
And with "8 Ball
Pool," you really
have created a title that
retains for quite some time.
So I wanted to ask a bit about
the secret sauce behind it
and kind of what you can
share, obviously, in this forum
that we can learn from, and
creating such a title that
retains for such a long time.
SAAD CHOUDRI: We
won't be sharing
ingredients, Iky, for souce.
No, we've been
going for five years
now, over five years it's
been out on the mobile,
and it lived on the web as well.
So, much like Playrix, we
started our life on the web.
It's very easy for
us to understand
that there would be a player
reaction towards this game.
So what we've seen
in terms of retention
is "8 Ball Pool" has
become almost a utility
for a lot of people.
It's a way for people to play
a competitive game on mobile.
Sometimes the traditional
retention for us
is not something
that we 100% always
are going to be
worried about too much
because, actually,
the way they are
is that maybe they go
away for about two months,
and they haven't
played the game.
But then eventually they'll come
back again and then fall back
into a pattern of playing
for like two or three weeks.
IKY SANDORFFY: Yeah.
Just a second.
Can everybody hear us OK?
Because I noticed
there was some--
No?
OK, got it.
SAAD CHOUDRI: It was
genius stuff, guys.
It was genius stuff.
I'll tell you what, I
did like five points,
on your D-30 retention.
It's unfortunate
for the front row.
SERGEI ZAITSEV: I
can confirm that.
IKY SANDORFFY: Very cool.
So we'll try to reiterate
some of the points that
were lost in translation here.
But-- ah, perfect.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Maybe not a vote.
IKY SANDORFFY: Maybe you
would like to reiterate.
No, Saad.
Just to repeat just
the highlights.
SAAD CHOUDRI: So,
basically just to repeat,
from a high level perspective,
we look at retention,
but "8 Ball Pool" had
been living so long
on many people's devices.
The way we reengage
players, and really,
we feel like it's more of
a utility now for people.
They come back and
they play this.
Even if they may have lacked
for two or three months,
they will come back and then
play for their regular session
lengths that we would expect
to see when they first started.
So we really spend a lot of time
on that aspect of our launch
strategy, and relaunching
games sometimes as well.
IKY SANDORFFY: Running
"8 Ball" as a utility.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Yes, sir.
Everybody plays pool, right?
SERGEI ZAITSEV: I know I do.
I can't judge from anybody
else, but I'm hooked.
And I have been for
quite some time.
So it's pretty
tricky to get off.
IKY SANDORFFY: Jens, you've
just launched "June's Journey"
with a really massive
launch, congratulations
on this first of all.
Yeah, it looks really amazing.
When we talked, you
mentioned that you've
created a really long production
cycle with a pretty long road
map of content updates,
life ops, and activities
that you're doing
in order to reduce
that original risk at launch.
I wanted to ask a
little bit about that.
JENS BEGEMANN: Yes
so "June's Journey"
is our latest hidden object
game, came out two weeks ago.
And there was really two
phases during the soft launch.
The first phase was OK, does
this have the retention metrics
that we need to have a
successful game long term?
That was something we looked
at between January and April.
And because we had a
previous hidden object game
before that was
a big success, we
could compare apples to
apples and we saw very early,
OK this will work.
Retention is good.
But then we had another six
month period, from April
to October, where it was really
about de-risking the launch
because life operations and
content are so critical.
So it's our highest
production value game ever.
It's our biggest content
effort game ever.
It's pretty ridiculous.
So we release a new
chapter every single week,
every Friday.
And every chapter is
1600 man hours of work.
So every Friday,
there's basically
a chapter that would
take 40 people 40 hours
a week to produce
every single Friday.
With people internally,
with outsourcing,
and it's ridiculous, but
we think it will work.
The first two weeks of data
indicate that this will work.
Our previous hidden object game
indicates that that will work.
We really needed
the preparation time
because we have an
author team, a writing
team of three authors.
They write about
a year in advance.
So they are currently
writing the story
that will appear in the game
in one year, next October.
There's graphic production
in between, etc.
So what we really did is we went
to the UK and we did something
we called dress rehearsal.
So we pretended we were live.
So we had weekly
content releases,
we had our weekly
reviews on marketing
spend, we did social
media, customer care.
We did everything as if
we were live globally,
just limited to the UK,
across all platforms.
And we didn't do that to
evaluate if the game would work
from a retention perspective--
we had already done that
before--
but to practice if we
could run life operations,
if we could run
content production,
if we could run localization
and all of those things.
And yeah, that was
really the key.
But it's a huge bet.
It seems to pay off, but I
had some sleepless nights.
IKY SANDORFFY: I cannot imagine.
So at what stage then during
that dress rehearsal did you
make that go or no go decision?
Was that like a set threshold
that you had set up front
or was it mostly--
JENS BEGEMANN: So
yeah, we already made
the "we will launch"
decision in April.
In April, we said we will
launch on October 5th.
Half a year in advance, we
set a specific launch date,
and we worked
backwards from that.
And we would have only
diverted from this
if we would have seen
something unexpected.
So we really used that
half a year to see,
is there something
unexpected coming?
To have those dozens of
people who are involved,
to basically prepare them,
and train them and get them
into the rhythm of what it
means to run a game with life
operations and content.
The five years after launch
is so much more important
now than the two years before.
And that's what we basically
prepared for in the last half
a year.
IKY SANDORFFY: That
said, you often optimize
during that period for
long term retention?
JENS BEGEMANN: We optimize
for long term retention.
I mean, one sentence
I say is, OK
you will lose a certain
amount of people
during your first week.
They may not like
the theme, they
may not like the
genre, but those
who are still with you
after a week you really want
to keep in the long run.
You really still
want to have them
after you that was the
mindset on content production.
IKY SANDORFFY: So from day
seven to day 28 retention,
you expect a minimal drop
off in order to justify.
JENS BEGEMANN: Actually,
with our hidden object games,
we've now changed, our reporting
system to measure day 720
retention because these
games are really about--
IKY SANDORFFY: Day 720?
JENS BEGEMANN: Yes,
two-year retention.
So we measure two-year
retention for cohorts
because long term retention
is everything for these games.
IKY SANDORFFY: That's
a good segue actually
to move on to George.
You've been running
your hit games
for the last couple
of years with King,
running the now very
famous "Candy Crush
Saga" and the entire franchise.
I had figured you also optimize
for the long term retention.
I'm wondering how you guys make
the decision between launching
a new franchise, to launching
a content update on one
of your existing titles.
GEORGE ABRAMOVICI: OK.
Basically, we had to
think about this strategy
around a few years ago when we
realized that "Candy Crush" is
here to stay for a long time.
We decided to build
two parallel tracks,
and one is keep working
on "Candy Crush"
and improve the game
and keep it fresh.
We are adding new
levels, updating
big extensions and new
content every second week.
Then, we also say we need
to also do something else,
so we followed this same--
these two tracks.
Investing in existing
games and also
working on launching new ones--
can be sister titles or can be
sequels to the original one.
But also new IPs as well.
IKY SANDORFFY: When
you do launch a sequel,
do you prefer--
essentially, are you taking
existing game teams or existing
stuff from the game teams in
order to develop that sequel,
or an extra dimension
where you actually
hired a completely
separate team to continue?
GEORGE ABRAMOVICI: It's a mix.
We also learned we need to use
the expertise from the people
that worked on previous games.
Some of them already know
how to build certain stuff,
and they're needed
in the new team,
but we also have
new things as well.
IKY SANDORFFY: Pretty cool.
It's working, clearly.
Definitely something
we can learn from.
Back to you, Jens, actually,
I wanted to ask specifically
about the inverse
of "June's Journey,"
of what we've just discussed,
of an experience you've
had as developing a game with
a relatively long schedule
and production cycle,
and where you ended up
with a decision of saying
this is not worth it.
We should actually roll back and
change, and move the research
to something else.
Deciding to kill
or roll back here.
JENS BEGEMANN: Yeah, we question
our productions all the time
and we actually stop
games at different stages.
So just a couple of days
ago, we stopped a project
that was already full
scale into production,
over 20 people team,
but it was still
over a year away from launch.
We saw too many risks
and in the end decided,
OK we'll stop this.
Not everything was shaping up
to give a very clear picture
of "this will be awesome"
because just good is not enough
anymore.
On this market,
you have to be one
of the best or maybe the best
in your genre to have a chance.
So that was really based
on relatively early stage,
and based on play tests
and subjective evaluation.
But we also stopped a project
in May that was in soft launch,
based on retention metrics.
Day one day three
retention was good
but then day seven, the drop
off of retention was too strong.
We just stopped that in
relatively early stages
of soft launch.
IKY SANDORFFY: So those were two
separate cycles, if you will.
One subjective playtest.
JENS BEGEMANN: One very
subjective playtest,
over a year away from launch.
The second one was after a
couple of months of soft launch
based on metrics.
IKY SANDORFFY: So, even
after the subjective measure
that we figured out it might
not hold up, the quality,
you still went--
JENS BEGEMANN: This
market is super tough,
I don't meet any developer
who says it's easy.
I never meet them.
So it's super, super tough.
You have to be one of the
best, and therefore the bar
is crazy high, and you
have to be quite ruthless.
Only if you're completely
convinced that this will
be great, you should continue.
If it's, oh, this is pretty
good, that's not enough.
That's not acceptable.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Can
I ask a question?
Because it's probably more
relevant for the room,
but everyone talks about
the retention metrics.
What is your bar?
You said you guys set
a bar, what's your bar?
Above the 40, 20, 10, what
are you guys looking at?
JENS BEGEMANN: What we do
is we look at days played.
For every install, how
many days on average
does that person
play over the year?
SAAD CHOUDRI: Right.
JENS BEGEMANN:
Over the next year.
That number can be high because
long-term retention is amazing,
or that number can be
high because everybody
plays for the first few
weeks and then drops off.
There, something in the ballpark
of days played of 30 to 40
is good.
You have 100 installs
and then on average they
play 30 or 40 days
during the year.
But obviously, monetization
is also important.
SAAD CHOUDRI: That's
30 to 40 sessions.
Separate days.
JENS BEGEMANN: Obviously,
out of those hundreds
installs, most of them play one.
Because if you have
50% day one retention,
that's already cutting.
Yeah that's the way
we look at it now,
because we think numbers.
Like, hey, day 30 retention
needs to be about 15%,
or day 30 retention needs to
be 20%, it's just one number.
You look at the
whole dropoff rate.
SAAD CHOUDRI: You use
the amount of days
that people play to figure
out your calculation.
OK, I think that a lot of
people are moving towards that.
JENS BEGEMANN: We making
LTV predictions, basically.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Yeah, that's
what I hope many people do.
JENS BEGEMANN: No, you have to
predict LTV during soft launch
and see where it ends up.
IKY SANDORFFY: That actually
brings up a really good point,
Saad, and specifically to you
and the recent launch of "War
Wings" and now just a little
bit surprised that we're almost
running out of time.
But just to quickly just talk
about the "War Wings" launch
because you really have
done something different
from your recent launches.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Yeah, we
went a little bit outside
of what people perceive as
our traditional comfort zone,
where we really launched a
fully 3D dog fighting game.
We, like Jens, talked
about the dress rehearsal
in one territory, so we had
already done the soft launch,
and then we essentially
focused on doing
a full, almost global
launch-esque campaign in one
territory.
We did that in the UK.
We did your full UA that
you would do, we did TV,
we did cinema, we
did a lot of things.
We worked with the platforms who
supported us on this endeavor
to try and see
what that would do.
Soft launch can give you a false
sense of security sometimes.
I think a lot of people, and
a lot of product managers,
and a lot og UA
teams will almost
do too well in soft
launch because they'll
have targeted the
users that they really
want and the metrics
start looking good.
Then you wonder why they haven't
scaled when you go into global.
They'll be like oh,
it's the featuring.
You get loads of these
casual audiences, guys.
I know you guys hear it, we
might as well talk about it.
So why we did that
is just to really get
a good sense of what that
would do on a global stage.
It's proven to be
successful, because it
replicated onto the
global launch, when
we pushed it out live.
IKY SANDORFFY: Would that
work for "Homescapes"?
Or would that have been a
good strategy for "Homescapes"
as well?
Doubling down on one
country and going all in,
or do you rather go
for a global launch
and then really see down the
line where you need to focus?
SERGEI ZAITSEV: It's
a good question.
We think that the
definition of a soft launch
should be different,
dependent on the context.
So if you go to the very
competitive crowded space
like mystery genre,
then then it should
release on the soft launch very
highly polished product, which
is pretty ready for
the commercial launch.
If you are missing
any of the features
that other competitors
have in the market,
then we will not make it.
You will not make it.
On the soft launch, we don't
test any mechanics or concepts.
We already are sure that
the game is in good shape.
But what they're testing is
retentions, monetization,
technical side, that
nothing crashes.
And then we also test
the difficulty curve,
which is gender equality.
We soft launch in Canada,
usually, and Australia.
We believe that
these metrics are
pretty reliable for
the commercial launch.
The period for which we soft
launch, it depends on the game.
And for "Gardenscapes," we soft
launched it for several months.
And "Homescapes", we kept it
in soft launch for one month.
We can rely on these numbers.
IKY SANDORFFY: But
it clearly worked.
All of you guys have been
really successful in launching
these games this year.
So we've taken a lot of
learnings from you guys
and really want to
share as much as we can.
I'm really afraid that
we're running out of time
and I think I have
to cut this short.
Although I think I could stay
here for the entire afternoon.
Do we have time for
questions still?
OK, cool.
If somebody here in the
audience has questions, please
raise your hand now.
It's a good time.
We have a couple more minutes.
OK, right here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hi.
It's a question for
Jens and Saad as well.
You both mentioned
you did a soft launch
and a real global
launch in the UK.
JENS BEGEMANN: We called
it dress rehearsal.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
What did you learn?
SAAD CHOUDRI: You
need a better name.
JENS BEGEMANN: Yeah,
what did you call it?
SAAD CHOUDRI: Soft
global launch.
JENS BEGEMANN: Soft
global launch is not--
SAAD CHOUDRI:
Somebody in this room
will come up with a better idea.
JENS BEGEMANN: Sorry
we interrupted you.
AUDIENCE: I was just
curious of what learnings
did you get from that?
You did the rehearsal and
then you presented with it.
Saad, you did all
your campaigns,
and did you learn
anything from it?
Did that affect the way you ran
the global launch after that?
SAAD CHOUDRI: Yeah, absolutely.
That's why you do it right.
Some of the channels in which
we had spent some marketing
dollars, we scaled that back,
other ones we put more into it.
For us, it was a new type of
genre for us to enter into.
We just really wanted
to make sure that one,
did our own network respond
to that kind of game?
What kind of UA channels?
Does brand marketing
campaigns work for this?
That's what we got from that.
We took that data back
and then rearranged
what we did for global launch.
We wouldn't have got that had we
not done that kind of process.
JENS BEGEMANN: I agree
to what you said.
For us, it was,
also, in addition
to this, because it was our
next big hidden object game
and we've got an
extremely loyal fan base.
We knew our best
users, our VIPs,
from our previous
hidden object game
would play "June's
Journey" on day one.
They need to have
a great experience.
Therefore, things like this
weekly content production,
which is crazy.
Every Friday releasing
a new chapter.
We wanted to have
practice in that.
We wanted to have practice in
a real market, with real users,
and with real customer care,
and with real social media
interaction, and with
real weekly pressure,
basically, on the
team, to, yes, this
has to be out, to see if
it really, really works
or if we would break
everything when we go global.
That, in addition to what you
said on the marketing side,
was important to us.
SAAD CHOUDRI: The
other thing we learned
was we launched tha
game, which is probably
sacrilege to say in here,
but the initial binary
download was 1.6 gigabytes.
So we needed to make sure
that we can do that globally.
In the UK, it works.
That was a big thing
for us to test as well.
IKY SANDORFFY: Nice.
We have time for one
more quick question.
First come, first served.
Let me summarize with one
quick question of my own,
the last one.
Just a flash question.
If there is one thing that
you would want this room
to take away, what's the
one KPI or the one tool
that the audience
should be considering
when launching a new title.
What's that key KPI
you're looking at?
George?
GEORGE ABRAMOVICI: For us, that
always has been and always will
be engagement, as well
as retention rates.
Understand why players
play your game, why
players don't like your game.
That's key to further
grow your game as well.
You need to know exactly
what are the pain points
and fix them as
soon as possible.
Very important for
launch, I would
say it's have enough content
for the most engaged players,
like you were saying, as well.
Don't underestimate that.
Just make sure that there's
enough content for the most
engaged players out there.
They can be very
vocal afterwards
if they run out of it, so--
IKY SANDORFFY: You don't want
to get your highest value
gamers getting
disappointed very quickly
and having finished
the game early.
GEORGE ABRAMOVICI: Absolutely
IKY SANDORFFY: I've been
affected with that myself
sometimes.
Having reached the end
of the game too quickly.
JENS BEGEMANN: In
addition to what
you said, George, on
retention during soft launch.
I think it's really when
you're super early stage,
or early stage, and you're
doing your play testing,
see excitement.
If you don't see
excitement among your team,
among people who play
it, very bad sign.
IKY SANDORFFY:
That's a good cure.
Saad.
SAAD CHOUDRI: For us,
long term retention
is probably the most
important thing for us
to look at and for.
The one issue that--
we've discussed this
in this industry
is funny, because 15%
D30, that is very good.
Or 10% D30 would be good.
That's kind of crazy to
think about your game started
with 100 users and
now you've got 10.
As an industry,
and as game makers,
and as content
developers, we're going
to need to improve
that in the future.
That ought to be very difficult
to have viable business going
down that route.
SERGEI ZAITSEV: I agree.
If it was only one advice,
just to focus a lot.
Focus a lot on the product and
focus only on critical things.
When you soft
launch a game, there
should be only a small list
of most critical things
that you should focus on.
You should ruthlessly drop
everything not important
and focus only on
important things.
What's important is always
dependent on the game,
on the context.
If you have a game with amazing
graphics, and the graphics
are the most important feature.
So you should make
sure that this is core
and you should polish it a lot.
You should care less about
leagues or clans for fair game.
But if it's a DVD
PUP game, then you
should make sure that
PUP is pretty polished
and graphic is less important.
This is Playrix's way.
We focus a lot.
We don't do many games.
For us, you will
see good results.
So I advise you to try it too.
IKY SANDORFFY: Content,
focus, retention.
That's essentially
the key summary points
that I'm getting out of here.
Gentlemen, thank you
so much for coming up
on stage and for agreeing to
share with the wider team.
I invite you all to come and
find our panelists afterwards
at the break if you
want to pick their brain
and get some more
specific advice.
I wish you a very successful
and valuable rest of the day.
Thank you very much.